[Music]
um
we have a new segment on this show and
because we're now a professional type
show
I've been waiting to show this emergency
by the way merch gave a lot of input
both all of us gave input but the final
product even surpassed that so here you
go the new segment all right
Sarah it is
[Music]
I love my mother
[Music]
scared after it
let's get after it wait wait wait wait
wait I'm going to I'm going to I'm going
here you go
[ __ ] bread
all right
oh [ __ ] man taper made the uh taper made
the image of course now with taper you
just give them taper's the best you just
give them an idea yeah and he threw and
he threw it together this is [ __ ]
fantastic shout out to my wife by the
way it's actually her idea she was like
look that Michael Strahan thing
everybody loved it because you guys got
to do them for Chris Cuomo now I I was
thrown around the idea of like
but Mercy is more definitely better idea
was like [ __ ]
making it seem like he's eating pasta
while doing it [ __ ] kills me so let's
get after it with Chris Cuomo uh hey you
know what Chris Como gonna talk to you
Chris Cuomo's actually reading or having
his producer read to him comments on his
YouTube channel oh great yeah so uh what
do you say guys you ready to get after
it I'm ready get after it had a
different take on your walk and talk
Jerry wrote Jerry Was a Race Car Driver
go ahead
what was that
God damn no no I know but is Chris Cuomo
singing Primus
yes I wouldn't think he's a Primus fan
there's a guy who obnoxiously sings
Sinatra at every karaoke you know it you
[ __ ] know it I did it my way we know
we did we know you did that's why you
got fired
news Nations Chris Cuomo should have
done it Jeff zucker's way you still have
a job or at least with Discovery one I
wanted to do yeah
now you're doing [ __ ] back and forth
with Bill O'Reilly on the disgraced News
Network thanks for having me Chris
boy we respect each other huh we love
each other so much
I like that this producer looks like
Stevie from [ __ ] eastbound It Was a
Race Car Driver remember that song no
what is that Primus Primus my name is
Chris
it's the [ __ ] dumb kid you don't know
nothing you don't know nothing you don't
know you don't know me you're so stupid
yeah you don't what do you know about
Winona's Big Brown Beaver man we're
known as Big Brown Beaver you don't
remember that you don't remember
Dinosaur Jr you're like the South Park
team yeah I mean they did the whole
thing
Tommy the cat Tommy the cat you don't
remember Tommy the Cat Daddy Chris Como
trying to [ __ ] shoot private songs to
his producer who's clearly a gay guy
that only listens to show tunes clearly
a gay 20 year old let's prime it what's
Primus is that what goes on before the
paint
yeah yeah that's what it is right the
euphinox like uh if it looks like Mr
Bungle
uh Jerry's the cheese this guy is a
total fake and he capitalized it is
who's guy you're the guy I think I think
he thinks you're a total oh I got you I
got you all right well here I am all
right man real reals rain okay you know
what I'm saying
why don't you read the real good
comments because I'm sure there's some
you'll even out we read the ones that
are fans yeah read the ones call them
Fredo let's see the [ __ ] let's see
the steam come out of this they count I
don't know do something for the camera
that proves that you're real no but what
I'm saying is look he's gonna Flex his
point is that I just noticed what his
shirt says
okay but you're not a free agent you're
not a free agent free agent you're not
fired and also isn't that kind of
disrespectful when you're on news Nation
to be wearing a free agent I'm sure news
nation has one of those month-to-month
things
you know what I mean
he has to pay to stream on there it's
one of those things he buys air time to
be a news Nation
he rents a chair from news Nation like a
[ __ ] hairdresser I was just saying a
barber
Royce you can't see the rest of the
shirt it actually says free agent for
spaghetti and there's an arrow pointing
to his tummy
yes I'm putting on one that looks like
the [ __ ] boogie board that uh Kenny
Powers had yes the Confederate flag and
the weed leaf
um why would I do that what what is my
ACT oh that you're not this uh super
villain that helps your brother do all
these terrible things look I don't know
how many different ways I can say by the
way hold on a second that guy all that
guy called him was a fraud he didn't get
into any specific fraud he just said
this guy's so fake a fake and then he
went into why he's got to bring on my
brother and it's like nobody did
Christmas no
in that question you leave my brother
out of this you leave my mother out of
this she's a saint on her
but why what a guilty conscience he went
back to it
I never did what I was accused of doing
and that I mean
but you did they have the emails Chris
that's okay it happens I gotta move
forward I gotta take care of what I can
take care of and I gotta forget what I
can forget and I'm not here to change
your mind about it I can only tell you
what's true
um so if you want to see me that way you
see me that way if you don't let me be
clear here Chris I thought you were an
absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] way before your
brother thing all right when you want to
hear the fist fights with people in the
village because they called you Fredo
that's what I was like this guy's kind
of got anger problem doesn't he yeah
yeah I mean you're you're irredeemably a
douchebag yeah it's nothing to do with
[ __ ] Party politics yeah some news
network you worked for you just sucked
you saw that in person we love you on
this show because how much you suck as a
person absolutely I walk and talk or you
don't believe that what I we love you
and the way we love Joe Pesci in
Goodfellas or Casino he's a [ __ ] not
a good guy but he's so much fun to watch
that's what you are talk about in terms
of vulnerabilities and struggle is and
CNN [ __ ] whacked you in a [ __ ] in
a plastic coated room
hey committee we're going to resign your
contract through that's okay I'm not
selling anything I don't even have a
book what do you mean you're not selling
anything well okay I don't even have a
book on like some cuomos that had a book
He's not selling anything and it's nice
to have the travel pass in fact I'm
still trying to figure out how to get
them without going through this offer so
you can get five free travel packs with
your first purchase he's not selling
anything bro it's not like I got some
kind of book on like certain brother of
mine who should have been focused on
covid you need one brother who's one
brother a certain guy about it I can
only tell you what's true
[ __ ] them
I'll tell you gonna be a fun
Thanksgiving what are you gonna do
Andrew well what are you gonna do huh
you're gonna end up under my [ __ ]
you're gonna end up in another sleeper
hold like you do every Thanksgiving you
might have been the big brother when we
were kids not no more
um so if you want to see me that way you
see me that way if you don't believe
that I walk and talk or you don't
believe that I believe you ex hold on
man this is this is what he always does
I believe you exist as a human I I know
for a fact you exist because you know
what Chris the truth of the matter is
besides you having a new show I've seen
hundreds of you I know we know what you
are I'm real look at me I'm right here I
made up of atoms and particles over here
all right
I'm real
you don't believe me honey you can touch
me hey don't let me introduce you not my
face don't let the [ __ ] face
I tell you what if you keep [ __ ] me
I'm gonna show you my electrons and my
protons oh thunder and lightning over
here I love the fact that he just flexes
them in my head he just flexes to
punctuate everything he says he's about
to meet Max caster and Anthony Bowens
over here he took an aw fan where did
that come from I live in Florida though
I have a billy gun so you better relax
two things I like I like pro wrestling
and I like Primus
I am the very real product of Mario
Cuomo and Matilda Cuomo who is a saint
she's a beautiful woman
and when I think of her
oh [ __ ] soul man it's just imagine
him fuming
pessie just reminded me of that Bobby
bottle service thing when he does the
cheating show and he's like
with my father
my father
when he cheat up much
and it's like they're rage
funniest sketches ever oh [ __ ] dude oh
[ __ ] is there anything funnier than a
[ __ ] insecure Guido it'll never not
be funny they are funnier and I've
somebody proved me wrong tell me if I'm
wrong they're funnier than wiggers oh
yes
there's a lot of similarities though but
there's a big sadness to awaker where
it's like whereas this is more of a
cultural oh like you don't outgrow it
you just get worse yeah there's no good
Fellas for wiggers I guess Malibu's most
wanted but I can't think of another one
hey you know Sheila underneath this Stan
chiseled physique is just a man who
loves his mother
that's what I talk about in terms of
vulnerabilities and struggle is true
that's okay I'm not selling anything I
don't even have a book you know that I'm
trying to tell you to read because
honestly I can't read if I'm being
honest with you I ain't good at it yeah
if anything I would have to buy I want
him ghostwriters I say the words to him
and he would type them down and a
typewriter or something
you mentioned a book somebody on the
couch confession or the Cuomo on the
couch series you have uh used to be
called couch confession this is Chris
Cuomo I want to talk about better help
I bet it is I bet I bet that entire
video about mental health is a better
health thing and let me talk to you
about patriot food buckets are you
hungry my friend my friend Paul he sells
these patriot food bacas he still
because he's Italian he has to sell the
food buckets by going like to be into
Italian about it so he's got to go hey
this is Chris Cuomo and I got a question
for all my fans out there gee
how about a food bucket you want a Full
Bucket
they got this big cdmr reader you
wouldn't [ __ ] believe you wouldn't
[ __ ] believe just like my muddy used
to make I'm just kidding she make beta
ZD in that but it's still it's all right
let's put good
you should write a book Chris
um I have almost for Better Health take
a teaspoon of olive oil every day your
health will be better there you go hey
Bing Bang Boom
write a book Chris
um I have a book mostly but you said
written wait no no but he's writing one
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't have a
book but uh stay tuned uh that I
co-wrote with somebody about what ah
there's the ghost please be your brother
no no no no no no no no you're going the
wrong way you're going the wrong way
please be your brother please be your
brother please be your brothers the Como
Brothers writing a book and every
chapter's them going back and forth
would be hilarious you know that [ __ ]
said on page 67 that I wasn't mom's
favorite I [ __ ] was I [ __ ] was
it's just a Cuomo sibling slam book
exactly
learn through the pandemic
and my own experience about lying about
being a you know isolation and actually
yelling at bikers at your second house
and then when I got [ __ ] tanned whoa it
got put on the shelf and now I I don't
know I don't know
if that's the right book anymore or if
it would be helpful to people because
that book was probably you puffing
yourself up and jerking off CNN and now
if you try to get that book out people
like man you were really nice of these
guys and [ __ ] you although you know it
is amazing to me how quickly we forget
things these days and maybe it would be
worth reminding what we went through and
what we learned I don't need another
Como writing a [ __ ] book about the
pandemic is this merch brought up
earlier the first one didn't go over too
well for the other guy what are you
talking about you won an Emmy or Oscar
for a book remember they took it away
from him after the whole you know
unpleasantness it doesn't matter it's
like it's like [ __ ] Lance Armstrong
he still won the Tour de France he gets
to keep the money [ __ ] yeah shut up
shut up with this whole oh we're
stripping them of this thing all right
then come take it I'll just get a
replica of the championship I won and
put it up in my house and it'll be
better quality I still want it yeah what
are you gonna do it's like if we ever
had like if we'd ever hit like a a
hundred thousand Subs on YouTube I would
have just bought a plaque and hung into
my house you think I need a [ __ ] oh
well YouTube will only improve of
certain well [ __ ] you I had a hundred
thousand so I'm just gonna get a plaque
I still got a hundred thousand I'll
[ __ ] screenshot the page it's all
proof I need and start calling us
calling ourselves YouTube's favorite
show
certified certified YouTube's favorite
YouTube's favorite show YouTube with the
like trademark logo and everything which
is totally used
this is by the way this is the last
thing a Thanksgiving turkey Sees at his
uh [ __ ] Thanksgiving you have the
turkey POV you're a turkey leg he's
fighting it with his brother
say one for Mom my likes one so they
fight for the other one all right but I
like the skin let me get some of the
skin you touch my turkey you [ __ ] what
are you gonna do you're not a [ __ ]
Governor anymore which one's the one
that eat Chris is the one who works out
he's probably the one that starts eating
before they do the prayer and he gets
his hand smacked yeah stop eating we're
not ready yeah we got through the
prayers first let's say grace sorry man
sorry Mom hungry I'm trying to cobble up
I don't understand I got a very narrow
timeline though yeah yeah Andrew's again
let you carbol out over the way at news
Nation where you at
am thinking very hard hey at least I
still put a suit on and go to a building
every day how about you how's he doing
how's that buck tooth brother took your
job huh Bailey won the [ __ ]
re-election over here getting a [ __ ]
Giants [ __ ] shirt that they gave him
one year I was wearing an old giant
shirt they went to a game about doing a
walking manual
I am all about the walking I can't
believe I waited this step in life I
wish step one walk every day even if you
got covered go for a walk walk around
even if you're in quarantine and then
when somebody calls you out for it you
threaten to beat them up
well I gotta tell you honestly for the
very first time we've done one I really
enjoyed
that let's get after it so I like the
let's get after it I love it
I know you are